[Musique]
quand j'ai dit que je voulais quelque
chose d'inhabituel
je pensais à un quelque chose que j'ai
jamais vu je voudrais quelque chose que
jamais personne n'a encore vu jusque là
[Musique]
où sens c'est quoi cette chose qu est il
est mignon
il s'appelle albert il faut le dire à
tes parents n'ont sûrement pas ils vont
rien comprendre
albert m'a choisie il est sous ma
responsabilité
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais vraiment expliquer à
quelqu'un ce que je fais dans mon labo
c'est top secret je veux pas qu'on
emmène bonjour ya quoi dans ce sac
ça me brise le coeur de voir une
créature comme ça enfermé dans une cage
albert ça va bien se passer
la grosse bestiole
elle ne devrait pas être dans une carte
vous n'irez nulle part dione carli
croiront jamais ça les règles c'est moi
qui les fais ici vous pouvez pas faire
ça pourquoi devrait-on avoir plus
d'infos voix clochard d'un gamin et de
son animal de compagnie
[Musique]